Redes neurais são uma classe poderosa de algoritmos de aprendizado de máquina
e elas vêm em muitas variedades
não tem como dar a devida atenção às redes neurais
em um vídeo introdutório
como este aqui vamos apenas identificar alguns componentes-chave
de uma rede neural e o fluxo de trabalho geral
para que possamos entender como a computação quântica pode contribuir
a rede neural é um grafo conectado de neurônios
um neurônio é basicamente apenas uma coisa que guarda um número
e esse número é frequentemente chamado de ativação: o quão
ligado ou desligado o neurônio está
os neurônios são organizados em camadas
e a primeira camada é a camada de entrada
e a última é a camada de saída
no meio há camadas usadas no processamento, chamadas de
camadas ocultas a ativação da
camada de entrada é simplesmente carregada diretamente dos dados a serem analisados
como o sombreamento de pixels em uma imagem
as ativações da próxima camada oculta são determinadas
pelos neurônios na camada de entrada
e pelos pesos simbolizados pelas linhas que conectam todos os neurônios
da camada de entrada a todos os neurônios da
próxima camada em outras palavras determinamos a ativação
de um neurônio na camada oculta
por uma soma ponderada de todas as
ativações de entrada podemos
também aplicar um viés um deslocamento
podemos querer ativar um neurônio
na camada oculta não apenas se a soma ponderada for
positiva mas apenas se ultrapassar um limite elevado
então frequentemente aplicamos uma função complicada para obter uma ativação
entre zero e um como uma tangente hiperbólica
ou às vezes de forma diferente uma
unidade linear retificada você não precisa se preocupar
muito com isso agora a única
coisa importante a observar aqui sobre essas funções
é que elas são não lineares
de modo que a rede como um todo contém componentes tanto lineares
quanto não lineares
a mesma soma ponderada de ativações desta vez
começando com as ativações da
primeira camada oculta com os novos pesos
se estende até a próxima camada oculta
isso continua até a camada final que é uma saída
a camada de saída tem neurônios correspondentes a
categorias e as ativações nos dizem
o quanto a rede tem certeza da classificação
então as categorias de saída em uma análise de imagem podem ser
cachorro gato hamster e assim por diante
e uma ativação de zero vírgula noventa e cinco no
neurônio de cachorro indicaria um alto grau de certeza de que
a imagem é de um cachorro você pode começar sua rede neural
com um conjunto aleatório de pesos
e vieses ou a partir de uma configuração inicial razoável conhecida
mas então a ideia é verificar
quão bem sua rede neural classifica as coisas
e melhorá-la usamos uma função de custo para descrever
como nossa rede neural se desvia da
classificação correta isso envolve calcular a
diferença entre o valor real de uma imagem
digamos por exemplo um valor de um no neurônio
de cachorro e zero em todos os outros neurônios de saída
e os valores previstos
somamos em todas as categorias
assim rastreamos não apenas se a categoria certa foi
a mais ativada mas também podemos
rastrear se ativações incorretas são reduzidas
somamos em todos os exemplos do nosso conjunto de treinamento
e obtemos um custo então
variamos os parâmetros como os pesos em cada camada
entre todos os neurônios e os vieses em todos eles
rotinas de otimização clássicas são usadas
para buscar um mínimo local na função de custo
se nada for feito para reduzir a complexidade disso
você pode imaginar que
espaço de parâmetros astronômico que criamos aqui
considere uma rede neural projetada para analisar imagens com
apenas mil pixels essa rede neural pode ter mil
neurônios de entrada apenas uma única camada oculta
e saída binária como gato ou cachorro
esse é o caso mais simples possível
e ainda assim corresponde a mil por mil
ou seja um milhão de pesos entre as camadas de entrada e oculta
e outros dois mil entre as
camadas oculta e de saída
possivelmente também mil ou
mais vieses então essa rede neural simples corresponderia
a bem mais de um milhão de parâmetros mas sendo justo
os algoritmos modernos normalmente fazem simplificações
em redes neurais clássicas
e existem campos inteiros dedicados a tornar essa minimização
possível e até eficiente
mas o fato é que esse é um problema de
altíssima dimensionalidade
e treinar uma rede neural
pode ser muito demorado
e custoso uma rede neural quântica ou QNN
funciona carregando primeiro os dados de entrada
e depois aplicando quantum circuits
correspondentes aos pesos entre as camadas
e finalmente uma camada de medição
alguns pontos-chave sobre isso os dados
de carregamento e as ponderações são operações lineares
mas as medições são não lineares
então, como nas redes neurais clássicas, temos
componentes tanto lineares quanto não lineares
além disso os weight circuits
ainda têm parâmetros variacionais
portanto ainda há uma minimização clássica a ser realizada
é claro que isso apenas arranha a superfície das redes neurais quânticas
mas esperamos que você continue aprendendo sobre as aplicações
de redes neurais quânticas
e outras aplicações de aprendizado de máquina quântico
com a IBM Quantum